how about this one
oh yes
i thought this was fake jay showed me
that can't be real he's probably just
[ __ ] around he watched a video like
oh half his face is paralyzed yeah
because they said he canceled his shows
in toronto they're like but it's not
covered to relate him like guys you know
he struggles with mental health and all
that [ __ ] like you may just depress
something if you don't want to dance and
sing in your hometown yeah but yeah no
he's like nah [ __ ] half my face is
paralyzed
and how did it happen
uh so so they think that uh when you're
like exhausted and stuff you can catch
these viruses so bell's palsy same kind
of thing bell's palsy can sometimes be
perfect it's a virus yeah
bell's policies that way you lose the
you the nerves just die in your face and
they'll come back but sometimes they
don't
my buddy my buddy half his face like
that well there's a rapper el chapo or
something like that he i guess he had it
and trying to contact bieber and there's
a hashtag
dr chopa was going around because he's
like hey i know the exact way to get rid
of this he's like hit me up i know
exactly how to deal with this because i
guess he had it oh wow
the painful rash around the ear on the
face around the mouth yeah
so it's probably it's not like a sun
that's oh that's what he has is ramsay
hunt syndrome that's what it says
and uh
how do you get rid of it
i think you have to wait it out you just
gotta chill yeah see if it's the same as
belle's palsy see what i see how it says
that
let me do this real quick how long does
it take to go away a few weeks
should get better in a few weeks there's
not much nerve damage you should get
better completely within a few weeks so
the damage is more severe you may fully
not fully recover wow but what but
it doesn't say what caught what
it's like
instead of virus viruses
patients with ramsay huntsman often have
more severe paralysis at onset oh that's
like i mean he used to dance dude and
they're less likely to recover
completely interesting
whoa he might have a little bit of a
lazy eye but you still dance and sing
it's [ __ ] up though man let me protect
that voice daddy yeah that's [ __ ] up
caused by the
varicella zoster virus yeah and shingles
damn affects the facial nerves
yeah i mean we've all stressed dude
that's stress and lack of sleep and all
that [ __ ] traveling
maybe i don't think you just got this
fire i don't think people realize what
someone like that like what the physical
exertion and the travel being on tour oh
my god like
uh
what's her name
uh the girl taylor swift yes
she had been touring for 365 days and
almost every other day or day she would
go to a different city she'd be on a
plane you go crazy that's a year-long
tour you make all the money but
oh it's a [ __ ] though think about that
she made 600 million dollars no but
you're shot chanting
you know you make a lot of money but
it'll she made all of it you don't take
care of yourself it'll [ __ ] you up
though you think you'd have someone like
there with your trainer with you a
dietician yeah because singing is
happening 600 million right
she's dancing and singing that's a
physical she's not dancing she doesn't
no no she don't dance anymore she don't
say that guitar flat ass
chin loves her shows jay they like this
the i like robots mine is my girl i
think she's amazing